[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All big ideas start with
a spark of inspiration.
Add in a dose of imagination
and a story begins to evolve.
As a story develops,
questions naturally
arise and lead to conversations.
Conversations that
explore, enlighten,
and spawn new experiments
where we ask: What can happen?
What is possible?
And then share these ideas
through compelling stories
to generate a new
spark of inspiration
and the next big idea.
Big ideas.
Real science.
Great stories.
That's Project Hieroglyph.
Read the book.
Join the conversation.
And share your ideas
for a better future
at hieroglyph.asu.edu.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ED FINN: Today I'm
going to tell you
a little bit about
Project Hieroglyph.
We're going to introduce
some of the collaborators who
have been working on this
product for the past couple
of years.
We're going to talk a
little bit about the book.
We have stacks of them
somewhere in the back.
We're going to have time
for question and answers.
The time for
question and answers
will come before the
time when many of you
will have to leave for
your 2 o'clock meetings.
And we're going end, as we
begin, with an invitation.
Hieroglyph is not
something that's over.
The book does not memorialize a
conversation that has wound up
and finished.
Hieroglyph is very
much just starting out,
and we frame the book and this
project is an open invitation.
So I hope that this will be
the beginning of conversations
with many of you.
What is Hieroglyph?
Let me start with a
little origin story.
Neal Stephenson, the
science fiction writer
who's going to be up here
on stage in just a second,
and the president of Arizona
State University, a guy
named Michael Crow, were at
an event in Washington, DC
a couple years ago, in 2011.
Like everything else,
this is on YouTube.
And Neil had recently
written an article
called "Innovation Starvation."
It was a polemic, an
argument about how
we seem to have lost our
ambition to do big stuff.
Going from the Apollo program,
grand national infrastructure
projects, really big thinking
about the world and the future
to paying other countries
and companies to fly stuff
into space for us, watching
those same grand national
infrastructure projects
crumble around us,
and adopting a much more
incremental notion of progress.
Now, I don't blame
you guys for this.
One of the reasons that
I'm excited to be here
is that I think Google is
perhaps the leading-- or one
of the most interested
institutions or entities
thinking about the
future in a more
creative and ambitious way.
But, by and large,
that's not how
we've thought about the future
in, say, the past 20, 30 years.
We've become increasingly
dystopian in the stories
that we tell about the future.
Increasingly cynical
about what we
can do to change the world
that we're going to live in.
And so Neal was
making this argument
in the context of innovation,
technological innovation,
the kinds of research
and money that
gets put into
different problems;
what problems we
choose to work on.
And Michael Crow, being the
sort of person Michael Crow is,
said well, Neal, maybe
this is all your fault.
Maybe the science
fiction writers
have been letting us
down because now we
have all of these
dystopian stories,
and if we don't have the right
kind of optimistic visions
about the future, how are we
going to build a better world?
How are we going to build
more optimistic realities?
That conversation
struck a spark,
and Neal began speaking to
friends and colleagues--
science fiction writers,
entrepreneurs, technologists,
creative thinkers of
many different stripes--
about a direct response.
How would we create a
new kind of conversation?
A new set of stories that
would be techno-optimistic?
That would take
seriously the challenge
of envisioning a future-- and
not a distant Star Trek future.
A near future.
An achievable future
that advances some kind
of hopeful vision of
the world while still
being technically grounded.
I think Neal's
ground rules were:
no Holocaust, no
hackers, no hyper-space.
And, at the same time,
Michael Crow came back to ASU
and we began talking about what
a university response might
be to this challenge; what an
institutional response might
be.
So the Center for Science
and the Imagination
is a platform for
this kind of thinking,
and we're the institutional
hosts of Project Hieroglyph.
Neal is its founder.
And over the past
couple of years,
we've been collaborating on
what we think of very much
as a community
and a conversation
much more than it
is a book project.
So on the inside, Hieroglyph
is about these collaborations.
It's about creating
a feedback loop
or-- it's about fostering the
feedback loop that has always
existed between science
fiction and science.
But it's about putting people
into direct conversation
and thinking about the outcomes
of this process as big ideas,
science fiction stories,
but also research
or inflections to
ongoing research,
changing curriculum,
public debate.
And of course for every
new idea, perhaps a hundred
or a thousand others
that come out of it.
A hundred or a thousand
other questions.
One of the things
we quickly realized:
When you begin taking the near
future in a science fiction
story seriously is that you
can't answer it-- you can't you
can't research that story or
address all of its questions
by only speaking
to one human being.
Any serious moonshot idea
about the near future
requires a whole host
of different disciplines
and a really creative
approach to what
you're trying to accomplish.
So on the outside,
Hieroglyph is something
we're describing as, "Big ideas.
Real science.
Great stories."
Grounded stories.
I often call them "science
fiction of the present."
So we had guidelines
for our writers,
because if you know
writers, you don't really
want to give them rules.
Guidelines are much better.
And one of the guidelines
was to write a story
that a young scientist or
engineer could read and achieve
within her
professional lifetime.
And, by and large, people
have followed that.
And our other
rules-- well, excuse
me-- our other guidelines,
encouraging them
to step outside of their
comfort zones and share ideas
before they're ready.
A traditional approach to
a science fiction anthology
is to say, hey,
we're writing stories
about Topic X. Do you have
a story about Topic X?
Why don't you send it to us?
And in a certain
sense, the same rules
apply for scientists
and engineers, who
are quite happy to talk about
published research things that
have been brought out
of the lab and vetted,
but it's a lot riskier
to talk about ideas
that you will have only
explore in the formative stage
or that you don't know if there
are some big holes in them yet.
Where you're actually taking
a risk just talking about them
before you've really had a
chance to think them through.
And Hieroglyph is
about trying to create
a safe place for everybody
to do that together.
For writers, scientists,
and engineers to all
kick around ideas, brainstorm,
before they're actually
ready to share those concepts
with the general public,
or perhaps to share them
within a disciplinary or peer
community.
So not asking writers to write
a story and come back to us
in six months, but
say, why don't you
write the story with us?
Why don't you collaborate
with us online?
And most of it has happened
online, on the Hieroglyph
website, and that's
where we want
to continue having these
conversations in the future.
Neal has engaged in some
prior collaborative projects
like this. "The Mongoliad"
is one well-known one.
And when I asked Neal how he
did the collaborative writing
for "The Mongoliad"--
which is this big, online,
very community-centric
narrative universe--
it emerged that there was
a big room with whiteboards
and swords in it.
And that's where the
writing happened.
If we did that, I think we would
lose something of this project.
It would no longer be the kind
of broadly public endeavor
that we want it to be.
ASU is an unusual
university not just
because it does weird
things like this.
It's most unusual
because it defines itself
by who it includes rather
than who it excludes.
And if you think
about it, that's
probably the single-most
radical thing
that a higher education
institution in the US
could do these days.
And so if we're
going to follow that,
then we can't depend
on co-location.
We can't depend on
personal invitations.
We can't depend on putting
people into a room together
who have the time and
the energy to be there.
We need to throw open the
doors in a much more ambitious,
maybe risky way.
For us, for the Center for
Science and the Imagination,
this is about a lot of
different objectives.
Getting a book out of
there is one thing,
but for us, again, it's
really just a beginning.
It's about inspiring
broad public conversation.
It's about understanding
the circulation of ideas
across very different fields,
very different systems
of imagination, which is an
ongoing research project.
And it's about
changing the world.
Having an impact with ambitious
projects and inclusive stories.
Stories that don't
depend on a particular
political or
technological standpoint.
Stories that envision
ambitious, radical change
in near-Earth orbit on
a voyage to other stars
but also right here
on planet Earth.
Stories about social change,
cultural change, as well as
technological and
technical change.
So we have a number of new
projects kicking around
in Hieroglyph.
We have a collaboration
with the World Bank
and other major
institutions, called
EVOKE, which is about
social entrepreneurship
and getting young people
in the developing world
to take a stronger
sense of agency,
feel empowered to create a
new story in their own lives.
We have an ongoing effort
around climate futures
and the imagination,
trying to come up
with more optimistic, engaging,
exciting, happier visions
of sustainability and
what the world might
look like in the near future.
And also, a related project
on science and science
fiction-- the feedback loop
between popular imagination
and technical progress.
So for the next
less than an hour,
we will explore a few of
these ideas circulating
through Hieroglyph, and
I hope engage all of you
in the conversation.
I'd like to introduce
Neal Stephenson and Keith
Hjelmstad to talk about
their collaboration
on "The Tall Tower."
Neal Stephenson is an author
of historical and science
fiction, a technology
consultant, and the founder
and principal provocateur
behind Project Hieroglyph.
He's the author of the
three-volume historical epic,
"The Baroque Cycle" and
the novels "Reamde,"
"Anathem," "Cryptonomicon,"
"The Diamond Age," "Snow Crash,"
"Zodiac," and coming
soon, "Seveneves."
He lives in Seattle, Washington.
Keith Hjelmstad is a professor
of structural engineering
in the School of
Sustainable Engineering
and the Built Environment
at Arizona State University.
He is the author of
the book "Fundamentals
of Structural Mechanics" and
serves as an associate editor
of the "Journal of
Constructional Steel Research"
and the "ASCE Journal of
Structural Engineering."
His research focuses on
computational mechanics,
earthquake engineering,
stability of structures,
non-destructive evaluation
of large structures--
which is really less fun
than destructive evaluation
of large structures--
and numerical simulation
of complex structures.
Please join me in
welcoming them.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Given the audience,
I'm eager to get
to the fundamentals
of structural mechanics
as soon as we can,
so I'll make a
brief introduction.
I actually talked about the
"Tall Tower" idea a year
and a half ago at
"Solve for X," which
was the first-- as far as I
know-- the first conference
that I was told about that
was organized by Google X.
And I did that in the world's
slowest after-dinner talk.
It's a talk that,
if you find it,
you should watch with your thumb
on the fast forward button.
Lots of majestic pauses.
I'm going to-- I bolted some
coffee before we started here,
and I'm going to try to get
through this a little faster.
"The Tall Tower" is both a real
idea and a kind of meta-idea.
It's sort of the first idea
we wanted to talk about
with Hieroglyph because it's
an example of the kind of thing
that makes a good choice.
It's very easy to
explain, simply,
"Let's build something
really tall."
It's an old idea.
It's not my idea.
It's something very visible
that anyone can kind of see in
their minds eye and
start thinking about.
For me, it emerged from some
papers written about 10 years
ago by Jeff Landis, in
which he pointed out
that is should be
possible to build really
tall structures out
of plain old steel.
And by "plain old," I
don't mean, necessarily,
hardware store steel.
But I mean relatively
high-quality steel
that is obtainable today.
Not super-fancy new materials.
And so I began doing
some work on that,
sort of performing some
simple calculations that
were kind of within
my comfort zone,
and rapidly reached the limits
of what I could really do.
Because when you
begin to figure out
the stresses that are involved
in a structure of that type,
it rapidly becomes
obvious that it has a lot
to do with wind loading
and other things that
go beyond my freshman
physics level of competency.
So through the good
offices of Michael Crow,
I was able to get in
touch with Keith Hjelmstad
here, and begin a conversation
about actually making
some more legit calculations
about what this thing would
have to look like structurally.
So that was probably a
couple of years ago now.
Probably exactly a
couple of years ago.
And so Keith began with
sort of a-- well, maybe
I should-- since I'm starting
to falter and stagger around,
maybe I should let Keith
take over for a second
and talk a bit
about what he did.
KEITH HJELMSTAD:
Yeah, so there I
was, minding in my own
business, and I get this call
from Neal Stephenson asking
about a 20-kilometer tower.
Actually, I think he
was worried about the 20
and he asked about
a 15-kilometer tower
as if that was going
to calm me down at all.
But I've been a
structural engineer now
for about 40 years,
and frankly, I really
hadn't given a lot of thought
to "How tall could we go?"
And I was immediately kind
of struck by the idea.
I'm not a real engineer.
I'm an engineering professor.
And so I think that gives
me a little bit more freedom
and license to
explore crazy ideas.
That's why I didn't hang
up on you the first call.
But I started out with
a pretty simple model.
At that time, I
did not really know
whether this was even possible.
So we've got a pretty
hefty gravity well here,
and I looked over the
papers-- the Landis papers--
that he sent me, and tried
to replicate that calculation
but noticed that the main
thing that there was missing
from that calculation
was the stability thing.
You can't just make a really,
really long, skinny thing
and expect it to stand up.
It's probably going to buckle.
But if you give it some width,
then maybe it will stand up.
And so I started out with some
pretty simple calculations.
Got
To a certain point
where I think I
was convinced that
it was possible.
And really it needed
more detail to it.
When you get into a
structure like that,
there's no precedent.
In fact, that's one
of the things that
was quite attractive
to me, because
in structural engineering we
live in a world of regulation
and building codes.
And in my view,
they've all but killed
the creativity in structures.
And here was something
that just wasn't
covered by any of those things.
In fact, there
isn't even a chapter
in "Fundamentals of Structural
Mechanics" that covers this.
It was sort of new ground.
But then I developed
a few more models,
some more advanced,
detailed models.
We ran into the problem of wind.
For those of you who are
structural engineering
interested-- around
here, earthquakes
are a pretty big deal.
But when you build high
enough, earthquakes
aren't really that
much big of a deal.
The wind is really
the main thing.
And if you build
20 kilometers high,
you poke up into the
jet stream, and the wind
gets pretty intense up there.
We don't know very
much about it.
And back to the comment about
how one person can't do it--
that's where I got
a little bit thin.
Even though in structural
engineering for things
that are fairly low, we
have mapped the whole world
and we can tell you how
hard the wind's going
to blow, or the
worst thing we can
happen in the region,
and things like that.
Nobody knows,
really, what's going
to happen in the jet stream.
And so that was kind
of the main thing,
and sort of where
we've gotten to.
We did have a model
of it, and the designs
were predicated on that basis.
But it's a pretty limited model.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah,
there's an interesting problem
you get into with-- what's
the granularity away
at which you're
sampling the winds.
The data that you can get
tends to average over both time
and space, and so you
can find a data point
saying that the maximum
wind at a certain height
at a certain time of year
is such-and-such meters
per second.
But that doesn't
tell you anything
about bursts that may occur
over a short span of time;
about how it may change
dynamically and perhaps get
oscillations happening
within the structure.
It tends not to cover
vertical movement at all.
And it doesn't cover small cells
within the larger structure,
where you may have kind
of anomalous conditions.
So the problem begins to turn
into a really interesting
problem of: how do
you-- first of all,
just how do you get the data?
What would you
have to do in order
to obtain enough
data about the wind,
to find enough level of spatial
and temporal granularity,
to actually be able
to build a legit model
of a tower this tall.
And it turns out that
we're nowhere near
having the kind of data that
we really need for that.
So that's kind of an
interesting problem
for potential
future exploration.
You can imagine
sending up-- you can
imagine sending up small
gliders that would just
fly around and gather data.
You can imagine a
program using balloons.
Right now, the way we do it
is that in about 100 places
in the country,
twice a day, they
send up a helium balloon
with a sonde on it,
and it records some
data as it goes up
and then it falls down again.
So that's the granularity
we've got now.
And you can imagine
how far that is
from what we would need
to actually model this.
So one of the
directions that we went
was to think in terms
of actually using
the forces of aerodynamic
lift in our favor.
The idea being that
if all you're doing
is pushing back against the
wind with the downwind leg
of the structure, then it
gets very heavy, very fast.
And so why not have some
lift-generating surfaces
that you could deploy on
whichever side happens
to be downwind at
the moment that
would use the force of the
wind that's trying to knock
the tower over to
lift up on that side.
And then of course you get
into further discussions of how
quick would that
control service have
to respond to changes
in the weather,
and so on and so forth.
KEITH HJELMSTAD: And
that was actually
kind of a new idea in my field
of structural engineering.
Because ordinarily we
don't build high enough
and you couldn't
make enough use of it
where that would be a factor.
And so this is kind of
a-- it's a new concept.
Whether this actually
would work or not.
Probably we need to sharpen
our pencils a little bit
and figure out a
few more things.
But one of the things that's
true about the tower-- it's
infrastructure in
search of a place to be.
And one of the things that
we talked about a fair amount
was where should you site it?
Could you get it out of
the path of the jet stream?
And if you did,
would you wind up
in a politically unstable
part of the world,
like the equatorial regions
and things like that?
The other part, which
I think is harder
to wrap your mind around,
is if you build such a thing
it's going to be there for
a very, very long time.
And it has to stand up to
absolutely everything that
comes its way for
all of that time.
You can't have a burst,
then it's like, oh,
we dodged that one.
Mother Nature doesn't ever
let you dodge any hazard.
And so thinking about how
many years-- a hundred years,
a thousand years-- it's
a pretty big investment.
And so it's got to
endure all of that.
NEAL STEPHENSON: You
want to talk a little bit
about the sort of genetic
algorithm stuff you've
got running now, and some
of the counter-intuitive
results that you've
been seeing from that?
KEITH HJELMSTAD: Yeah,
so the design problem
is kind of unprecedented.
And then the question
comes up, "What
shape should the tower be?
What should it look like?"
And this was kind of an
intriguing thing for me
as well, because we do
we train new engineers
but we kind of
train them to fall
in the footsteps of
everything that's been done.
And the creative process
needs to come out somewhere.
And here's a case
where we actually
don't know what would be the
best shape of this thing.
And it's one of
very few structures
that we're really worried
about keeping the weight down.
Usually you welcome more weight,
because it anchors things.
But this is-- weight's
quite a premium.
And so my initial thoughts
were: You make it tapered
so it's narrow in the jet
stream and broad at the bottom
so it's stable and
doesn't want to tip over.
But we've recently done
some modeling with shape
optimization, using
genetic algorithms,
and we're getting some
very interesting results.
Because of that, we envision
the design of the tower
as being in sort of this
hyperbolic paraboloid shape.
But in order to tie
all of that together,
this thing covers
about 11 square miles.
All the members have
to work together,
so you tie it together with
big ring-like structures
at the bottom because
the angle of the legs
are starting to splay
out a little bit.
They put pretty intense
compression into the ring,
and that's unfavorable from a
structural engineering design
point of view.
And so the genetic
algorithm is starting
to tell us that
wouldn't actually
be the best shape, in that it's
trying to find a shape that
doesn't cause that
unfavorable compression,
working a little bit more
toward a tension structure.
And I, frankly, I did
not see that coming.
And I have a graduate
student who's
been trying to convince
me of this for some time,
and the arguments are
getting better and better.
ED FINN: So, I think,
Keith, you already
answered my next
question, which is,
what has this
collaboration changed
for you in your own
professional practice?
And we've already heard a
little bit about your students
and how radically
different this problem is
from other problems that are
set for undergrad and graduate
engineers.
But Neal, do you want to talk
for just a minute as we wrap
up about what was different
about this from a writing
perspective, from other
projects that you've done?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Well, just whenever
you're writing hard SF, you're
typically kind of on your own
in terms of trying to sweat
the technical details.
And so sometimes
you've got people
you can reach out to who can
give advice on that front,
but it frequently is
somewhat elicit-- a back room
kind of process.
Because it's, in a sense--
and Kathryn can actually
speak to this a little
bit-- it's risky.
It's a career risk to be, say,
a junior faculty member who
gets cited by a
science fiction writer.
And so here was a case
where I had access
to Keith, who was
exactly the right guide
to be thinking about this.
And it was OK for him to do it.
It was being directly
encouraged by the president
of the university.
And so as you'll see if
you read the anthology,
that's a pattern
that we tried-- not
"we," but the
people that actually
put the book together-- tried
to replicate in giving some
of the other writers access as
they needed it to people who
could help them with
the technical content
of their stories.
So I think that's kind
of a new and good thing,
and something that may yield
interesting results if we
can keep it going in the future.
ED FINN: So thank you both.
I'm sorry that we have to
keep things so short today.
But let me turn things over to
my co-editor for the volume,
Kathryn Cramer, and
she'll talk a little bit
about this from a science
fiction perspective.
And then we'll have a couple
of other collaborators come up
to speak as well.
KATHRYN CRAMER: In
July of 2011, Neal
asked me whether I was
interested in editing
a book like this.
And so here we are
three years later.
It took us only three
years to do this.
So what Ed asked me to do
was to talk about, "Why
optimistic science fiction?"
And this sort of got-- as I was
working on it in the wee hours
last night-- it also got
a different title, which
is "Why Hieroglyph Is A Verb."
In the 1920s, Hugo Gernsback
named our genre "science
fiction."
And he described it as
an engaging narrative
that had science and
scientific content, and also
visionary prophecies.
And ever since he
named it-- in fact,
about the whole time
since he named it--
there has been, to some
extent, a debate over optimism
versus pessimism
in science fiction.
And over that time, many
different binary oppositions
have come into play
in the discussion.
And I made a list
of a bunch of them:
Golden Age SF
versus the New Wave.
American SF versus British SF.
Science fiction versus
speculative fiction.
Cynics versus Pollyannas--
which comes up
a lot when we talk about
the concept of Hieroglyph,
by the way.
Happy endings versus downers.
Sympathetic characters
versus unsympathetic.
Ideas-driven stories
versus character-driven.
Clear journalistic
prose as opposed
to stylistic sophistication.
Populism versus the literary.
Realism versus the fantastic.
And Benford's phrase,
"Playing with the net up,"
rather than fanciful fabulation.
Free will versus predestination.
Militarism versus pacifism--
which specifically
comes to bear on the
Star Wars defense system;
there was a group of science
fiction editors-- hard
SF writers-- who
were in favor of it,
and then another group
of hard SF writers
that were opposed to it.
Utopia versus dystopia.
Activism vs learned
helplessness.
The influence of Henry
James versus the influence
of H.G. Wells.
Genre fiction versus
stuff supposedly so good
that it's not SF.
What is, contrasted
to what could be.
Now that last pair
is the one that's
most important to
Hieroglyph A lot of them
bear, in one way or another,
on the specific stories
in the book, and
there's a lot of stories
where you could say,
"Well, this is hard SF,"
or, "This belongs in
Hieroglyph because of this,
but doesn't meet that criteria."
But where we really
live with Hieroglyph
is in the gap between
what is and what could be.
Our future is full
of possibilities,
and Hieroglyph invites
you to explore them.
While as editors,
Ed and I want you
to have the best possible
time reading our book
and it really enjoy your reading
experience, what we really
care about is not so much
how you feel as what you do.
In the Gernsback tradition--
in the Gernsbackian tradition,
Hieroglyph is a visionary book.
But Hieroglyph's goal is not
so much to predict the future
as to inspire.
To engage writers
and scientists,
engineers, and other
creative thinkers,
with science and technology's
utopian potential.
The future doesn't just happen.
Moment by moment, we invent it.
Some of us invent
futures for a living.
And I think it's--
on the one hand,
there's us from the
science fiction field,
and those of you from Google
who are inventing the future
and a whole different
way, which--
I kind of enjoy that
moment right now.
But if we don't
invent the futures
we want to live in,
who will do it for us?
Ursula Le Guin said, "Great
artists make the roads."
There are precursors
to Hieroglyph
that I feel we
should acknowledge.
And this also, by the
way, could function
as a recommended reading
list for what else
to read other than
our lovely book that's
in the back of the room.
Geoff Ryman's anthology,
"When It Changed."
Ryman believes that science
fiction writers should
rely less on what's
called "rubber science"
and he put scientists
together with his writers.
Jetse de Vries did an anthology
of optimistic science fiction
called "Shine" in 2010.
And then, I'm not
sure if you guys
have a subscription to "Nature"
here, but now the futures
column in "Nature,"
founded by Henry Gee.
I've published
three stories in it,
and in general it's
a terrific series.
And just by coincidence,
"Natures 2,"
their second collection, also
came out yesterday, in addition
to Hieroglyph.
And then MIT's
"Technology Review"
occasionally publishes SF.
And then there's SF short
stories sponsored by Intel,
and a program run by
Brian David Johnson.
And another precursor
to Hieroglyph
is the design fiction
movement with which
Bruce Sterling is associated.
And while we were
doing this anthology,
Gregory Benford,
who's in our book,
was also doing an anthology
called "Starship Century,"
which focused on space travel.
That was sort of
edited in parallel,
and there is a certain
amount of overlap and content
in both stories and, I think,
at least one illustration.
And then there is the discipline
of Foresight Studies, which
both Madeline Ashby and
Karl Schroeder studied
in graduate school.
And then of course there
are the individual authors,
such as Kim Stanley
Robinson, who've
been writing this way all
along, without needing
us to tell them to do it.
In 1978, when I was in high
school, my father, John Cramer,
became a science columnist for
his favorite science fiction
magazine, "Analog," which was
formally known as "Astounding"
when it was edited
by John W. Campbell.
"Astounding" was the flagship
magazine of Golden Age science
fiction.
And by the way, when Neal
was invoking Heinlein, Clark,
and Asimov-- the sort of
Holy Trinity of hard SF,
we're talking Golden Age AF.
When my dad was an
undergraduate at Rice,
he submitted his first attempt
at stories to Campbell.
And this was very
meaningful to him
later, when he was nominated
for a John W. Campbell
Award for his hard science
fiction novel, "Twistor."
And when I became a science
fiction editor in the 1980s,
that was the job I wanted.
But unfortunately
for me, Stan Schmidt
retained that job from the
1970s up until two years ago.
He only just retired.
So instead, I edited
about 30 anthologies,
including two hard
SF anthologies,
"The Ascent of Wonder" and
"The Hard SF Renaissance."
In August of 1967, my parents
through a farewell party
for a man who was leaving
Seattle to go to Mars.
Yes, Mars.
I remember the condensation on
the glasses of the adults' gin
and tonics, how the
condensation bent the light.
And him leaning
against the dishwasher,
talking about training
to become an astronaut.
I was five years old.
Joe Allen was leaving the
University of Washington
nuclear physics
laboratory, where
he was a postdoc, to join NASA
as one of the first scientist
astronauts.
There would be Apollo
missions, which
would be followed by
laboratories on the moon,
and then there was to
be a mission to Mars.
You know he never got there.
Nor did he get his
lunar laboratories.
But he did get to space.
We are asking science
fiction to change.
We are asking for a
science fiction that
won't hang back
and talk to itself,
but instead will leap
at the opportunity
to change the world
in the future.
Like all writers who come here,
we want you to read our book,
and we want you to tell your
friends and even your enemies.
But we also want more of you.
We want you to participate
in the Hieroglyph community
and imagine better futures.
We want you to think
about infrastructure.
Which is, I think,
by the way, what
this book is
fundamentally about.
Hal Clement, when asked why
his stories lacked villains,
replied that the Universe
was antagonist enough.
Think long term.
Think survival, not just
for us as individuals,
but for humanity as a species
and for the species that
are on this Earth with us.
We are on the surface
of a planet right now.
And astronomy teaches
us how rare and precious
is this Earth.
Let us learn how to remain.
Our book is the beginning
of a project, not the end.
We want to do more
books, but also we
aim to broaden the project
to reach many more people.
We would like to work
further with NASA.
We would like to work on
subject areas such as climate
change, sustainability,
genomics.
We would like to expand to
novels, graphic novels, TV
and film, while at the same
time producing tangible research
results.
We hope for your help
and your support.
Hieroglyph isn't just
a book; it's a project.
It's not just a
project; it's a process.
And I will go so far
as to say, for me,
Hieroglyph has become a verb.
"To hieroglyph": to
refine an idea such that
it becomes an icon in a language
for solving problems most
in need of solutions.
And I'll repeat that, since
it's a little complicated.
To refine an idea
such that it becomes
an icon in a language
for solving problems most
in need of solutions.
This is what Neal Stephenson
does exceptionally well.
It's why you all came here.
You can do it too.
Let us all go forth
and hieroglyph.
Thank you.
And now, I will introduce
two of our authors.
Rudy Rucker here [AUDIO OUT]
short story in 1987.
He's a science fiction, author,
philosopher, mathematician,
one of the founders
of the cyberpunk--
this is dropping in and out.
Is it going to stay if I talk?
OK-- one of the founders
of the cyberpunk movement.
He worked for 20 years as a
computer science professor
at San Jose State
University and has
published a number
of software packages.
His novels include
"Turing and Burroughs,"
"Jim and the Flims,"
and "The Big AHA,"
as well as "The
Wetware Tetralogy"
and a four-book cyberpunk series
that won two Philip K. Dick
Awards.
Our other author
who's going to join us
is Annalee Newitz, who
writes about science,
pop culture, and the future.
She is the editor-in-chief
of "io9," a publication which
covers science and
science fiction.
She is the author of the book
"Scatter, Adapt, and Remember."
Is that one book or two?
"Scatter, Adapt, and Remember"
is one book?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: All one book.
KATHRYN CRAMER: It's all
one book, "Scatter, Adapt,
and Remember: How Humans Will
Survive a Mass Extinction
and Pretend We're Dead."
Oh, no!
ANNALEE NEWITZ: "Pretend We're
Dead" is a separate book.
KATHRYN CRAMER:
It's not quite all--
there's one-- there's an
"and" that's not in italics.
I You fooled me!
ANNALEE NEWITZ: One's about
surviving, one's about dying.
KATHRYN CRAMER: OK the other
book is "Pretend We're Dead:
Capitalist Monsters in
American Pop Culture."
And she's the co-editor
of "She's Such a Geek."
Formerly, she was a policy
analyst for the Electronic
Frontier Foundation
and a lecturer
at the University of
California-Berkeley,
where she received a Ph.D. in
English and American Studies.
RUDY RUCKER: Hi.
I recently was reading a
novel by Charles Stross,
he's one of my favorite
science fiction writers,
and he was talking
about a guy who
says he has Impostor Syndrome.
And I'd never heard that phrase
before, and I looked it up.
And it's something that
some well-known people have.
They feel like they're faking.
So I taught software engineering
at San Jose State for 20 years
and I don't know anything
about programming.
I was faking.
And I've published 20 novels,
and I don't know how to write.
I've been faking.
And I'm in the
Hieroglyph anthology,
and I'm faking
because I'm not making
any constructive suggestions
about the future.
I thought I would come
up with one specific idea
that, actually,
you could implement
using Google's technology.
It would be pretty easy.
It's something I
call the lifebox.
And this is an idea
I've been talking
about for 20 or 30 years.
Recently some people have
tried to commercialize it.
And the idea is fairly simple.
You'd like to have something
like a website that
would simulate you,
sort of like something
that passes the Turing Test.
So if somebody wanted to talk
to me, they'd go to this site
and they would ask questions and
the program would answer them.
And it would basically feel
as if they were talking to me.
And I realize there's a
pretty easy way to fake it.
I have a page called
"Rudy's Lifebox."
If you root around on my
blog, you can find it:
rudyrucker.com/blog.
And then there's
Rudy's hyphen lifebox.
And you can restrict
Google Search so it only
searches one website, so it
just searches all the files
that are on rudyrucker.com.
And I have a lot
of things up there.
I posted a lot of
books, a lot of notes.
And one thing I found with the
links that you get from that,
if you put up a PDF,
it isn't really good,
because-- I don't know why
it is, something about Google
versus Adobe or something-- when
they return you a link to a PDF
document, it's just a
link to the document
and it's not a link down into
the site in the document.
So it's slow.
It's not a good interface.
So because of that
I've been going
to the trouble of posting
things like-- whenever I write
a novel, I post a
book-length bunch
of notes about how
I wrote the novel.
While I'm writing a
novel, I write the notes
so then when I don't want to
write, I can write the notes.
And then when I'm done,
I put the notes up,
and nowadays I put them
up as big web pages
so that you can
search into them.
And so that's-- really,
you don't need the AI.
You can fake AI if
you have enough data.
That's the whole thing.
If you have maybe 10,000
pages that somebody's written,
you can always find the
right thing in there.
I think they tried doing this
with the fake Phil Dick head
that they made, that they
lost on the airplane.
And they had-- it would
search through his works
and find phrases.
And I think this could
work pretty well.
It'd be a good product.
People would like it.
And there are some
sleazebags trying
to monetize this product.
I call them sleazebags
because they
don't mention that I
had the idea first.
But I don't care enough about
it to try to monetize it,
so I'm giving you this.
OK, so that's all I
have for right now.
KATHRYN CRAMER: Annalee?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: OK, so, I
have some biotechnology here,
by the way.
This is not actually
not technology.
I just want to note
that about paper.
So my idea for the
book, for Hieroglyph,
came out of the book that
I published last year,
"Scatter, Adapt, and Remember,"
which is pretty optimistic
because I talk about humans
surviving a mass extinction,
which people seemed to think
was radically optimistic
that we would make it through.
And one of the solutions
that I proposed,
and that lots of the
scientists and engineers I
talked to proposed,
was that we'll
survive by creating
more sustainable cities.
Bigger, more high-tech,
but more sustainable.
So the interesting
thing about thinking
about these future cities
that would be sustainable
is that, I think when
most of us imagine
awesome cities of the
future, we picture something
like a city that's like an
Apple watch or something
out of Tron Legacy.
Right?
Like curves, and shiny
and clean and chrome.
Something with soaring towers.
I actually think
that's possible.
But it's also possible that
a city of the future that
was sustainable would look
like a very ancient city.
So let me give you an example.
Let's talk about St.
Louis, because St. Louis
is interesting for
a lot of reasons.
For one, its
industries are highly
dependent on fossil fuel.
It's a coal-based economy there.
And also, St. Louis is
located right across the river
from an ancient city.
It's about 1,000 years old.
It had about 30,000
people that live there
for several hundred years.
And what dominated the
horizon of the city-- which
is called Cahokia now,
and you can actually
see some of the
remains of that city
that weren't knocked down for
the freeway-- the city was
dominated by these
huge earthen pyramids.
Enormous!
Basically like the
pyramids in Egypt,
but made from hard-packed earth.
And so it's my
proposal that we think
about that as a kind
of a model for how
a city might look in the future.
And I have one
magic word for you
about how it's all
going to happen.
And that word is
"cyanobacteria."
So if you're a scientist,
you might call a cyano
if you're working with it.
You might know it
as blue-green algae,
and you've seen it
all over the place.
It's a model organism that's
used a lot in synthetic biology
because we understand a lot
of the metabolic pathways.
We understand a lot of the
genetic pathways that run it.
And there's actually a
lab in St. Louis, run
by a guy named Himadi
Pakrasi, that's figured out
a way to tweak the genome
of a certain strain of cyano
to produce a lot more
hydrogen than it had been.
And this could be used,
putatively, for hydrogen fuel.
And so I think that a future
that's-- I think that we could
start thinking about a future
where instead of investing
in new ways to suck fossil
fuels out of the planet,
we start thinking about ways
we could use synthetic biology
to alter microorganisms
to produce fuel.
And I think that might be--
that killer app, killer
biological app-- might be
the way we'd kind of get over
the hump in terms of
bringing synthetic biology
into our cities as
something that we could
use not just for making
fuel, which is awesome,
but also for building with.
So instead of living
in houses and buildings
that are made of dead
materials like dead trees;
if you're building
anything with calcium,
calcium carbonate
in it, of course,
you're building
with dead bodies.
And so these are
dead structures.
But what if we were building
out of living structures?
What if we altered plants to
do things like filter our air?
Filter our water?
What if we grew cyano not
just for energy production,
but to produce other kinds
of chemicals as well.
And of course there's all kinds
of labs around the country
right now where this
stuff is going on.
Where we're altering things like
yeast and other microorganisms
to produce chemicals
that now are
produced through messy
industrial processes.
So the synthetic biology city.
Let's just imagine
for minute that mound
that I was talking about.
So you're going into St. Louis.
You're going to work at Google
St. Louis let's pretend that
exists.
Does that exist?
I don't know.
Anyway, so, you see
this huge mound,
which is basically
the equivalent
of a skyscraper in the city.
So first of all, because it's
this mound and you've got,
say, shops in it, you have
offices, you have living areas.
So it's already well
insulated, right?
Because you've got the
perfect earthen mound,
so it's going to be cool
in the summer and warmer
in the winter.
It's shot through with
all kinds of tunnels
that are for bringing in fresh
air, which of course is being
filtered by microorganisms.
You've got ways of bringing
water into the structure
so that you don't have this
problem where you're keeping
water out of the structure
and therefore you
get all this water
runoff, which is
one of our big problems
with ocean acidification,
among other things.
And this mound is
covered in plants.
All these biologically
altered plants
that might be part of the
building's filtration systems
and part of its metabolism.
And so part of what
we're thinking about here
is: What would a city be
like if it functioned exactly
like, or very similar to,
the ecosystem around the city
itself?
The city is becoming
its own ecosystem.
A genetically
modified ecosystem,
but one that's
diverse and in balance
with the life around it.
So say you're coming into work
and you see this building.
One of the other things
you might see on this mound
is that it's not smooth.
I mean, we've already said
it's covered in plants,
it's covered in some grasses
that help with water runoff.
But it's also covered in a
lot of pock marks and scars.
This doesn't look like the
shiny Tron Legacy future
that you might imagine.
And the reason why
it looks like that
is because this is
a structure that's
being repaired constantly,
using bacteria.
So say it develops
a crack, or there's
some kind of other
structural damage.
You might use a form of
bacteria to repair that crack.
The bacteria would
go in, replicate,
extrude some kind of glue,
and harden into concrete.
And if you sat down at your
computer in this building,
which would probably be made
with virus shells-- modified
viruses producing shells
that produce a computer
monitor for you-- that's, by the
way, being done in a lab right
now at MIT-- you might look out
the window of your nice office
in this mound, and see
something really extraordinary.
Somebody in that future, in
this synthetic biology future,
will have taken
Stewart Brand's advice
and de-extincted mastodons.
To bring them in to eat grass
and to stomp on the roads
to keep the dust down,
and maybe trim the bushes.
And all of that,
this future where
you have a sustainable
building that functions
like an ecosystem, and mastodons
outside, will come from a world
where a simple tweak
to cyanobacteria
might usher in a future
shaped by synthetic biology.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So this
is great, and thanks
for doing this and coming here.
Imma let you finish
and all, but I just
wanted to say in
a contrary vein,
as a field don't stop doing
the pessimistic stuff.
Because I think as
engineers our failure mode
is we're too optimistic,
and we need somebody
to write the unit tests
that we have to pass.
Right?
So I want to know if I'm
making a program, what
are all the ways
it can go wrong?
I'm not good at thinking
of them, but you guys are.
So keep doing that too.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Thanks.
Thanks, Peter.
Kathryn can actually talk
to this a little bit,
but I'll say that
there's more-- but when
I saw the stories
they came out I
was pleased by how
much bad was in them.
People didn't go too far in
the optimistic direction.
And indeed, my story
about the tower enlivened
by a giant lightning
bolt strike from a thing
called an upward super-bolt
that kills somebody.
So I think the dystopian thing
has gone too deep into our DNA
at this point ever to go away.
KATHRYN CRAMER: Yeah.
A touchstone phrase of mine
when we were editing the book
is that one wouldn't want
to write in an airplane that
had been designed by somebody
who had never thought
of the possibility
that planes crash.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I had a question.
You were talking about a
very biosynthetic future.
Have you heard
anything more recent
about, say, cultured
meat, or anything?
Does that come through any
of the stories in Hieroglyph?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: I can't
speak to other stories.
NEAL STEPHENSON: I don't think
we have any meat stories.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: No meat stories.
We also don't have an artificial
womb so, what the hell?
But what I will
say is that I think
any kind of utopian vision that
includes synthetic biology has
to include some kind
of synthetic meat.
Tissue-engineered meat.
I love to think about it.
In my story I do talk
about a warehouse
where they're growing
sort of sheets of meat.
And I think that's-- I
mean, it's not just humane,
but it's also a better way to
not perturb the carbon cycle.
Because, I mean,
frankly, there's
less farting if you
have sheets of meat.
Right?
Like it's going to be a better,
more sustainable system.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no,
I definitely really
like those properties of it.
It's not cruel.
It's not--
ANNALEE NEWITZ: One
day it will be tasty.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But then
you start getting
into problems where
it's a monoculture.
You've got this whole
sheet, but it's all
weak to the same
bacteria or virus.
RUDY RUCKER: I have quite a
bit about artificial biology
in my story in there,
"Quantum Telepathy."
And that's something that's
always interested me.
That we could eventually
get rid of all the machines
that we have.
I mean, it would be more natural
to have everything be alive.
We used to talk about
nanotechnology a lot,
and really biology
is the nanotechnology
we've already got.
We've really just
haven't even scratched
the surface of what we can do.
Speaking of cultured meat,
in my novel "Freeward,"
there's a woman-- and I
think she's a senator--
and she produces meat
made from her own cells.
It's called "Wendy meat."
She's very popular.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: But I just want
to add that I think that as we
think about these features we
do have to think about how do we
introduce diversity
into our manufactured .
Biology because diversity is
what's key to any ecosystem,
so ecosystem engineering has
to include a focus on that.
So that you won't have all your
meat getting the same disease,
or all your cyanobacteria coming
down with some kind of rot.
ED FINN: And of course
this is a problem
with industrial
agriculture now, right?
We have fewer and fewer species
of that plants and animals
that we're relying on
to mass produce things.
KATHRYN CRAMER: Actually, I
want to point your attention
towards an essay that was
posted on the Hieroglyph website
a couple of days ago.
I don't remember
exactly the title of it,
but it was the
solar punk manifesto
that dealt was the some
of the issues in terms
of small-scale infrastructure
as a form of resistance
to large-scale infrastructure.
And I think in that framework,
diversity in biology
is a key issue.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious about
the genesis of the project.
You mentioned that there
was a conversation about us
as a society not
thinking big anymore.
And it made me think that I
feel like around here there
are a lot of people
who are thinking big,
but our society has sort of--
we've sort of tied ourselves up
in knots.
So, like, your super-tall
tower idea sounds amazing,
but around here it's illegal
to build tall buildings.
We have the anti-invention of
the high limit to deal with.
So I'm curious why you think
the problem is that nobody
has designed the 20-kilometer
tower yet, when we can't even
build a 100-story
building around here.
NEAL STEPHENSON: I actually
don't think that anymore.
I actually-- since we
started this project,
my thinking has been going
in the direction of, "What
actually is the
scarce resource?"
And my first inclination
was to believe
that the scarce resource was
clever ideas, because I think
of myself as a clever
idea kind of guy,
and how flattering
it is to think
that I'm what the world needs.
But it turns out that just
probably within this room,
there's enough clever
ideas to absorb
the gross national product
of the United States
for a number of years in R&D.
So the scarce resource
turns out to be
the sort of intangible things
that we need within a society
to mobilize capital
and to get these things
actually moving forward.
And that then turns into an
interesting conversation about,
is it regulation?
Is it the legal environment?
Is it something to do
with how capitalists
assess risk versus reward?
I wish I could give
you a pat answer,
but I bet Rudy's got one.
RUDY RUCKER: Well, nature.
You can always look
at what nature does.
There's lots of
things competing.
And I certainly agree that
we don't want monoculture
with crops.
It's just lots of
seething things.
And people worry if you
do artificial biology,
there will be some
creature you make
that's going to be
like this super,
super-slime that's
going to eat everything.
But you need to keep in
mind that every living
creature on earth
has been working
to the very limits of its
capability for a billion years
to try to dominate earth.
So it's not that they are
not already trying to do it,
but they keep each
other in check.
It's not like we're going
to do something better
just because we're scientists.
We'll work on
something for a week
and we're not going
to-- so I think
that we can count on
the evolution of nature,
but how to take over
politics, I don't know.
I have to ask, as long as
I'm here, how many of you
have read "The Circle,"
by David Eggers?
Not too many people, yeah.
It's sort of a "1984"
take on Google.
It's a real page-turner.
Makes you think twice.
But enough said.
[LAUGHTER]
NEAL STEPHENSON:
One of the stories
in Hieroglyph, by
Karl Schroeder,
actually is about politics.
So he actually went there
and addressed the topic
of how might the way that
we prosecute politics
change in the future, as
a way of actually enabling
it to get things done that
we're not getting done now.
ED FINN: Yeah.
Another way of addressing what
you guys are talking about
is that this is about
frame narratives.
Right?
You can spend all the
time in the world having
the battle with the City
Council about how tall you
can build stuff.
But if you can come up with a
new story that's compelling,
and if the people have a
different understanding of what
a building is or what
we might do with it.
What if a building is a city?
What if a building is
an elevator into space?
Right?
ANNALEE NEWITZ: What if
it's a living organism?
ED FINN: What if it's alive?
Yeah.
Well, what if it's a kite?
Then that changes--
you know, learning
to see the frame narrative
and figuring out ways
you can change that
framing narrative,
that's how you overcome
these other problems.
It's a little bit like getting
a job in a very specific field.
If you if you keep playing
the game by the rules,
you're never going
to win the game.
You have to learn how
to move the goalposts.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: The good news
is politics are always changing.
We think that there's this
sort of static narrative
of the bad guys always win,
or the powerful people always
crush the powerless people.
But it's not always true.
Things change a lot.
Things have changed a lot
just in the past 10 years
that we've seen.
So we can intervene,
and things will change.
And so maybe one
day, San Francisco
will be a high-density
city with tall buildings.
Wouldn't that be nice?
KATHRYN CRAMER: And I
should say, on our way here
we saw several large signs that
said "Neal for City Council."
So maybe he'll change things.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: As kind of a follow
up to the last question,
the sort of canonical example
of the last really big, crazy
thing we did was
the Apollo program.
That kind of the
early '70s, which
coincides with the beginning
of the great divergence
and the beginning of the
fall of the public's trust
in government.
NEAL STEPHENSON: What's
the great divergence?
AUDIENCE: Oh, pardon me.
Between around-- from about
the time of the New Deal
until around the 1970s, rising
tide really did lift all boats.
Everyone's incomes
kind of got closer.
Poor people were better off.
After the 1970s, the gains
accrued to the very, very few.
Including the
people in this room,
but not very much below here.
So do you see the
causality going--
the being interested in
doing big things going hand
in hand with her failures
a policy and loss of faith?
Which direction you see
the causality going in?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Well that's kind
of how this the
conversation started,
as a sort of
conversation between me
and Crow about which direction
the causality arrow pointed.
So I'm not going to tell you
that I know what the answer is.
This is one of those
"when you have a hammer,
everything looks like a
nail" kind of conversations.
So the thing that I've
been kind of officially
certified by my civilization
as being qualified to do
is to write science fiction.
And so if I'm given an
opportunity to do that,
and a university
president is telling me
that maybe it'll
help, then I'm there.
I'm a happy guy.
I don't know whether--
so, part of what
we're trying to figure out
is whether that actually
does have any useful
causal effect.
KATHRYN CRAMER: One thing
that was interesting about how
the book turned out
is-- I mean, there's
the themes we
asked for, and then
there was what's
common in the stories
we're actually publishing.
And one of the surprise
themes of the book is empathy.
There's a lot of stories that
are engaged with empathy,
both just sort of thematically,
but also in some ways
as a technological problem.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: But also, I just
want to add in direct response
to that question, what happens
when you have extreme class
divisions in a culture and the
middle class is disappearing?
Which has already happened
in other parts of the world.
So we're just-- the US
is kind of catching up.
That means that fewer and
fewer people are allowed
to be authorized, like Neal,
to have ideas and participate
in making decisions about
what a nation will do next,
or what a university
will fund next,
or what a pharmaceutical
company will fund next.
And the more homogeneous
that group gets,
and the more we
exclude people from it,
the fewer and
fewer ideas we get.
Because of course,
ideas-- we were just
talking about
diversity in nature,
and I think the best ideas come
from diversity in humans too.
It's just good sense.
And so I think if
there is-- I also
think there's no simple
causal explanation.
I think that would be silly.
I wish there were.
But I do think that
there's a correlation
between a difficulty
in coming up
with big ideas and a culture
that's strongly class-divided.
RUDY RUCKER: I have one more
thing to say about that.
One of the other paradigms,
besides getting the public
to chip in a very large amount
of money to make a giant tower,
or to map the genome, or
to build a highway network,
is more of the indie,
do-it-yourself ethic.
It's the old punk thing
of turning your back
on the authorities
and doing it yourself.
And that was sort
of-- that was one
of the elements of
cyberpunk, is the concept
that you can have these
off-the-grid sorts of people.
Like Blank Reg in
"Max Headroom."
And they're doing it and make
it happen in their own ways.
That's something
Cory Doctorow has
been writing a lot in his recent
books, like "Pirate Cinema."
And I think there's
some hope with that.
This said, to make a really
massive, key technical
scientific breakthrough,
it's not clear
that Santa Cruz stoners can
do that in their kitchen.
[LAUGHTER] Maybe they can.
Let them try.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
So I'll just try
to quickly say there's sort of
three general ways-- paradigms
for organizing a bunch of
geeks-- that I think of.
And one is the hacker,
edge-dwelling kind of people,
exemplified maybe by Linux.
One is the kind of Stalinist
government-funded program.
And one is the big
company doing it.
One of the interesting
things, to me,
about the results of the
Hieroglyph experiment
was that there wasn't a
lot of the third thing.
There wasn't even a lot
of the second thing.
So there was a still a pretty
strong reliance on the outsider
hacker-type self-organizing
to make stuff.
I thought it was
interesting that it seemed
to reflect a kind
of lack of vision,
or lack of faith in the
ability of big institutions--
be they governments or
companies-- to actually
mobilize engineers
and get things done.
Which I think is funny,
because that's actually
where engineers are
employed and do things.
But seen from the
outside, there seems
to be a lack of
faith or optimism
about the ability of big
companies to do stuff.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: I have lots
of municipal governments
in my story.
NEAL STEPHENSON: There you go.
ANNALEE NEWITZ: I have faith
in the municipal government.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Actually, I want to kind of--
it's rather a specific question
about the tall tower idea.
I mean, in software
we kind of are
taught to write code that
kind of fails graciously.
So the question would be:
How would the tall tower
fall graciously?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Keith's all over that!
KEITH HJELMSTAD: It wouldn't.
There would be a
massive catastrophe.
There's no such thing as a large
structure falling gracefully.
AUDIENCE: That's an excuse.
You know that, right?
It will fall.
But how do you make
it fall graciously?
KEITH HJELMSTAD: It won't fall.
Ever.
[LAUGHTER] After the Earth
has banished all species,
there it will be standing.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
In the story, just
to avoid worrying about it, I
stipulate that downwind of it
there's a big thing
that's literally
called "the swath," which-- the
billionaire who makes it just
buys all of that land.
And so the way he
shuts people up
when they're worrying that the
tower's going to fall over,
is that he says, "If
it starts to fall,
we'll just dynamite all
of the legs on that side,
and the entire tower will
just fall like a tree
down the swath, and
we'll keep the swath
empty in the meantime,
to minimize the fallout."
But that's me.
That's not a legitimate
engineering contribution.
AUDIENCE: One
thing I've enjoyed,
slash, struggled with
in Neal's writing
a lot is that it's really hard
to remember what he's making up
and what is factual.
And that delight
and frustrates me.
And I'm wondering,
how in this anthology
did you-- did the writers
manage to walk that line so
closely, where you have
to keep track-- wait!
Did I read about that in a
novel or a science journal?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Well, that sounds
like what Rudy's been
working on with his notes,
his ongoing note-keeping system.
I'm terrible at that.
RUDY RUCKER: I do like to
have a coherent theory.
That's one sort
of-- you might say
that's one difference between
science fiction and fantasy,
is fantasy you're not required
to have a coherent underlying
theory of why the
events happened.
They're just there.
It's sort of like X-Files.
It's strange!
What if?!
But if you're writing something
that's more like hard science
fiction, then you make
up-- like, somebody
use the word, "rubber
science," or-- that's
a bit denigrating--
nonstandard science.
You add on some
extra principles.
I got my Ph.D. in mathematical
logics, and as I said,
I taught programming
for 20 years.
So I like the idea of
having a logical system
and either deducing
things or-- it's
like if you have a program,
you look at the outputs.
So I like whatever
I'm doing in the story
to have an underlying theory.
And I don't actually start
with a theory and work out.
I start with the
effects I want to see.
I want to see something
really cool, like a tower.
And then I want to
see people flying.
And I want people to have
telepathy with each other.
Then I say, OK, so how are
we going to make this happen?
And that's-- the technical term
for what you're looking for is
what's called a
"bogosity generator."
So you get your bogosity
generator, but you make logic.
You build it solid.
You don't just throw
together some woo-woo crap.
You've got something--
you make up whatever.
Dark energy is great. you know?
[LAUGHTER] 90% of the
universe is dark energy.
That sort of tells you
something, doesn't it?
90% of the universe is bullshit!
So it's all about
keeping a straight face
when you're writing the story.
You just pile it on and
you keep a straight face.
ED FINN: One of the fun things
about-- That was a good answer!
But one of the fun
things about this project
is that it's not entirely clear
whether some of these stories
are really science
fiction at all anymore.
There's a story called, "Johnny
Appledrone vs. the FAA,"
which is about the
near future of drones.
And it's not-- there's
really nothing,
I think, in the story that's
technically impossible now.
And obviously,
certain people seem
to be quite
interested in drones.
And Cory Doctorow's
story for the anthology
also involves an
area of research
that NASA and the European Space
Agency has funded for, I think,
for several years on what
I've recently learned
is called "in situ
resource utilization."
What if, instead of
carrying everything
you need to the moon, you
can use all the resources
on the moon or on Mars?
Other destinations?
To 3D print, or otherwise
fabricate the materials
that you need.
The most implausible
stuff in Cory's story
is not that, I think.
It's about other social features
of the near future society
and economic predictions
about how expensive
it will be to launch
stuff into space.
KATHRYN CRAMER: One thing
about the organization
of Hieroglyph as
a book, is there's
a lot more "showing
your work" in it.
We have the authors
write stuff about where
they got their ideas and how
they work them out, and so on.
So in a usual science
fiction anthology,
we try to hide all that stuff
so that you just believe as much
of it as possible.
But because of the
nature of this book,
we exposed a lot more than
we otherwise would have.
NEAL STEPHENSON: That's
actually sort of a Cramer family
tradition.
KATHRYN CRAMER: Yes!
NEAL STEPHENSON: In
"Twistor," at the end,
he adds a little
technical appendix
explaining the bogosity part.
He says, well, OK, it's
all true up to page 93,
and then he gives a
complete sort of physics
explanation of where he departed
from something you could
put into a
peer-reviewed journal.
MODERATOR: Last quick question.
NEAL STEPHENSON: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I've been told
I need to keep this quick.
The thing most like near sci-fi
that I've heard of recently
is Bitcoin.
It's kind of crazy.
And I was just hoping
that you guys might
give an idea of-- is this a
step on the way towards utopia
or dystopia?
Like, I can't--
RUDY RUCKER: Neal has a Bitcoin.
He showed it to me at lunch.
[LAUGHTER]
NEAL STEPHENSON: Someone
gave me a Bitcoin.
ED FINN: Let me channel
Karl Schroeder for a second,
since his story-- he
actually got in touch with us
in the middle of
production and said,
"I have to revise my story to
include the block chain, which
is the central
technology of Bitcoin.
It's something I've become
quite interested in recently."
But basically, Karl
is taking the lead
of people who are saying
Bitcoin-- don't think
about Bitcoin as a
system for currency.
Think about it as a system for
democracy and authenticating
stuff through a
peer-to-peer network.
And so he-- Neal
already mentioned
that his narrative is about the
political, potential political
impact of technology.
Could you solve
consensus-based decision-making
if you just had better
Wi-Fi and better interface
tools for getting people to
understand issues and make
decisions about them?
And so he really wanted to make
sure the block chain was part
of that, as another
tool that you
would use to authenticate a
consensus-based decision model.
So I'm not so sure, but
Karl thinks it's utopian.
Thank you so much.
This was great.
[APPLAUSE]